red bear scoring an exclusive interview
with former president Donald Trump and
Grilling the GOP front-runner on
everything from his indictment to the
2024 race
the only way Nara could ever get this
stuff this back would be please please
please could we have it back because
they have no we would ask for it no and
they said can you give us the documents
and we would talk and then they said
they went to doj to subpoena you to get
which they've never done before and you
know why not just hand them over them
because I had boxes I want to go through
the boxes and get all my personal things
out I don't want to hand that over to
Nara yet and I was very busy as you've
sort of seen yeah but according to your
diapers you then tell this aide to move
to other locations after telling your
lawyers to say you'd fully complied with
the subpoena when you hadn't but before
I send boxes over I have to take all of
my things out these boxes were
interspersed with all sorts of things
commingled the word Brett uh uh what
what is the what's the thing you want to
tease that happened tonight that ever
what did you learn from this interaction
by the way that's really nice it's not
the accordion though yes the accordion
but um listen he is very defiant as you
can kind of tell he is very maybe he
wasn't supposed to talk about all that
he talked about but we went down to the
Weeds about this indictment and I
followed up continued following up uh
some of the things that are in there and
he talked about them
um he does not fear going to jail he uh
thinks he is in 100 percent the clear
and he believes it's all a political
Witch Hunt as he said before but he says
it in a little different way tonight
what did he think about the growing
Republican field
he is uh seems solely fixated on
Governor DeSantis he talked about him
the most I asked him is that because he
thinks he's the number one threat he
said no it's because he's the closest to
me and he's not that close and he
pointed out the polls many times
but on policy we went around the horn
you know he's getting hit from the right
on Criminal Justice Reform on abortion
and he really talked in depth about what
his policy positions are did you get
into any foreign policy with him tons we
went around the world China Russia
Ukraine Saudi Arabia he really went off
on The Binding Administration on China
and specifically the president's
statements about the balloon being an
embarrassment and not threatening
good oh
um if you covered it what do you think
he would say or what did he say was
something that he would change about his
approach from 2020. I asked him that
specifically okay and he said I wish I
could be less controversial
but I can't because the Press won't let
me and the only way he can get his
message out is by being more
controversial that's what he said and
what is he relying on that he thinks
will ultimately put him on top
well he thinks that he's just a better
candidate he talks about the issues if
he gets substance out there and he
thinks going head-to-head with Biden
will be easy once he gets on the debate
stage I asked him if he's going to be in
the debate in August in Milwaukee he
hasn't fully made up his mind but he's
wondering whether he should be in there
because he's up 50 points he says
and you're moderating that debate
I don't know am I that hasn't been
announced officially yet because I
thought I thought
iterate with you
I I assume I'll be somewhere around
Milwaukee at that time okay good we have
another clip
that's the clips are fun come on yeah
let's do it go for it guys
should Taiwan be independent
so if I tell you an answer it's going to
hurt me in negotiations on the
assumption that I went
but I have a very good relationship with
President XI after covet came in I sort
of didn't want the relationship and I
sort of ended the relationship after
having made one of the greatest trade
deals ever made including usmca Mexico
Canada is tough if China invaded Taiwan
[Music]
because that hurts me in negotiations
with regard to president XI now he knows
what I do and by the way for four years
they didn't invade Taiwan and they never
even talked about it
it was really interesting he did he did
that on China and Russia saying his
force of Personality on the
international stage prevents these Bad
actors from acting bad and he really
talked about the negotiations that he
thinks he can get done behind the scenes
yeah and the right answer is also one
that allows you not to give an answer
unfortunately but that is like you're
not supposed like that's his whole you
know game plan my dad knows that sitting
on the podium in the white house when
you have those questions that on foreign
policy are nuanced you only step in it
when you because it's so interesting to
have you ask him with these questions
rather than the ones that answering them
in 2016 was very different then he
answers them now because he has so much
experience and he knows the people
personally he's probably one of his
strongest suits is his foreign policy
and how he could go against Biden on
that Rhonda Sanders Etc they don't have
that yeah and if the media would just
let him be less controversial
it really is
Litany of things that he said it's a
long list does he think Newsom is going
to get involved in in the race he didn't
talk about it he thinks uh Biden's in it
you know and thinks it's in it to the
end interesting all right I'll see you
on the panel okay I'll be in Bedminster
by the way oh just
so you know okay sounds like there'll be
some golf in the morning all right Brett
thank you you can catch Brett's hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else